et pour en parler nous sommes avec
laurent brun secrétaire général de la
fédération cgt des cheminots
bonjour bonjour merci d'être avec nous
sur rt france le gouvernement affiche
donc sa détermination à quelques jours
de la présentation du projet de loi
devant le conseil des ministres ce sera
vendredi prochain le 24 janvier qu'en
pensez vous bac c'est une détermination
de façade en fait tout le sketch qui a
été monté autour de l'âge pivot a fait
un flop complet
la population reste très hostiles à la
réforme les mobilisations se poursuivre
dans les entreprises donc ce
gouvernement il n'a plus qu'une chose
c'est impressionne impressionné les
gaules avis tenté de les dissuader
poursuivre leur action parce que si nous
poursuivons l'action mais il va être en
très grande difficulté pour justifier sa
posture
donc nous nous continuons l'action et
nous appelons les salariés à se
mobiliser encore plus nombreux justement
deux nouvelles journées d'action sont
d'ores et déjà programmé une
manifestation du 24 janvier donc le jour
où le projet doivent être présentés
devant le conseil des ministres
quel va être le programme de cette
journée ces journées de grève et de
manifestation nous voulons en faut en
faire un temps fort particulier il ya
aussi le 22 et le 23 qu'ils seront
constitués d'actions locales et d'action
professionnelle mais le 24 on veut
vraiment que la population descendent
dans les rues et donc nous lançons un
appel à tous les salariés de ce pays
pour se mettre en grève est pour aller
en manifestation le 24 pour dénoncer
cette réforme qui va diminuer nos
pensions le gouvernement espère un
essoufflement progressif de de cette
contestation est ce que vous pensez que
ça va arriver ou alors le gouvernement
il joue cette tactique depuis le début
puisque vous rappeler qu'au départ il y
avait
une tentative de focaliser sur les
régions spéciaux puis ensuite il ya eu
l'épisode de la trêve pendant les fêtes
à chaque fois il espère que ça va tomber
aujourd'hui
évidemment il ya certains secteurs qui
sont fatigués puisque chez les cheminots
on est à 45 jours de grève ça pèse
énormément donc il ya une diminution
dans ces secteurs là mais on voit bien
que ça émergent à d'autres endroits
qu'il ya un bouillonnement de
mobilisation qui fait qu'en fait le le
conflit ne ne diminue pas et puis
l'opinion publique reste farouchement
opposé à ce projet de réforme
edouard philippe a jugé que la grève à
la sncf et à la ratp était sans issue et
n'avait que trop duré je le cite vous
représentez les cheminots que vous
inspire cette déclaration oui c'est les
déclarations d'intimidation qu'on a
connu aussi au moment de la trêve de
noël et à d'autres périodes de luttes
sociales le gouvernement devrait plutôt
être en responsabilité et chercher le
moyen d'arrêter de fracturer le pays
aujourd'hui le pays est fracturée par la
mobilisation
s'ils gagnent en imposant ses vues à
tous les salariés qui sont en lutte le
pays restera fracturé pour ressouder le
pays il faut retirer ce projet et
repartir à zéro
le premier ministre aurait confirmé
cette détermination à reculer l'âge de
départ à la retraite mais qu'est ce qui
fait penser à cela justement en fait
tout le système de 2,6 le système par
points
au niveau des retraites est basé là
dessus puisque le principe c'est qu'on
va pouvoir moduler la valeur du point de
manière à diminuer les pensions et on
sait très bien que quand on diminue les
pensions
on oblige les gens à travailler plus
longtemps donc en vérité c'est pour ça
qu'on le disait que l'âge pivot est un
peu de l'enfumage
il n'y a pas besoin d'acheter vos dans
un système par points il suffit de
diminuer la valeur du point ou en tout
cas de ne pas l'augmenter aussi
rapidement que la valeur d'achat et vous
avez
diminution des pensions et donc des gens
qui prolongent leur activité donc la
nature de ce système là c'est ça c'est
de pouvoir permettre une augmentation
continue et infini je dirais du temps de
travail dans la carrière quelle solution
selon vous pour les salariés grévistes
sncf qui qui ne vont toucher aucun
salaire ce mois ci alors nous avons
d'abord des caisses de solidarité
notamment une caisse nationale on va
répartir l'argent sur les grévistes qui
se sont le plus mobilisés donc on a
identifié au niveau de la cgt les 5000
grévistes les plus impliqués dans le
conflit depuis le début ça veut pas dire
qu'un avec 5000 milliards est beaucoup
plus mais cela ils ont fait énormément
de jours de grève on va leur apporter
une aide financière ce sera évidemment
très modeste puisqu'on parle de 100 à
150 euros
donc c'est très modeste mais malgré tout
on essaye de faire fonctionner ce la
solidarité localement il ya aussi des
des caisses de solidarité et puis
ensuite je pense que les grévistes qui
se sont fortement impliqués dans le
combat ils sont complètement convaincus
de la légitimité de ce combat donc oui
c'est un sacrifice ça va être dur on va
on va souffrir mais on veut aller au
bout et on veut gagner surtout voilée à
partir du moment où on est persuadé
qu'on gagnera l'investissement il n'est
pas il n'est pas catastrophique hier le
taux de grévistes à la sncf était
retombé à 4,6 pour cent avec deux
conducteurs de trains sur dix en grève
c'est ce qu'avait annoncé la direction
dans un communiqué la grève la grève est
elle encore retenus à bhl oui ben on est
on est sur le noyau militants on va dire
qu'il continue la grève
au quotidien et qui maintient la
pression au quotidien et puis on a des
remontées forte au moment des temps
forts des appels interprofessionnelle
donc nous ne sommes plus le fer de lance
de la mobilisation puisque à partir
qu'on régule non on est à 45 jours de
grève qu'on est dans la septième semaine
évidemment ça ça se sait ça me fatigue
mais malgré tout la remontée au moment
des temps forts montre que les féminines
ont malgré tout ils sont quand même
toujours hostile à cette mobilisation et
il faut que d'autres salariés prennent
le relais dans l'est dans les
entreprises privées dans les dents les
grands services publics de manière à ce
qu'on ne continue cette bataille
collective est en tout cas les cheminots
sont pas prêts à arrêter définitivement
la grève un échec pourrait il entraîner
un recul de la cgt lors des prochaines
élections professionnelles à la sncf je
ne pense pas alors d'abord on regarde
pas vraiment ça quand on est dans une
bataille mais je ne pense pas parce que
je pense que ce qui ressort c'est que la
cgt elle a fait tout ce qui était
nécessaire de faire ensuite c'est les
salariés qui sont propriétaires de
l'action et du résultat de l'action nous
en tout cas notre force organiser nos
structures que ce soit jusqu'à philippe
martinez ou en redescendant jusqu'aux
syndicats de base
tout le monde l'a fait ce qui va ce
qu'il a pu pour porter la bataille et on
continue d'agir dans ce sens là donc je
pense que la cgt avait plutôt conforté
par le salarié en tout cas c'est ce
convoi nous au niveau des adhésions chez
les cheminots
les cheminots qui se rendent compte
qu'en fait il faut renforcer cette
organisation syndicale pour être plus
efficace dans les conflits vous êtes
confiant sur le fait que cette réforme
des retraites puisse ne pas être
présente et enfin ne pas ne pas aboutir
oui je pense que politiquement le
gouvernement n'a plus d'options soit il
fait des concessions aux professions et
il va mécontenter la population et il va
se priver c'est tous ses soutiens les
plus à droite qui veulent une réforme la
plus radicale possible
soit ils passent en force contre
l'opinion publique et les deux options
sont quand même très très risqué
politiquement
donc je pense que ce gouvernement il a
plus beaucoup d'options c'est pour ça
qu'ils essaient d'intimider les
gaullistes et 2
masqué un peu la réalité de la
mobilisation merci beaucoup
laurent brun je rappelle que vous êtes
secrétaire général de la fédération cgt
des cheminots merci d'avoir leur souffle
à nos questions